deadly tornados sweeping through one of
those Super Tuesday states Tennessee at
least two tornadoes touched down
including one that caused heavy damage
near downtown Nashville we're just
learning and we're learning that at
least seven people are now confirmed
dead in the metro area emergency crews
are dealing with about 40 collapsed
buildings CBS news meteorologist and
climate specialist Jeff burrow Delhi
shows us what happened it's a scene of
utter destruction in Metro Nashville
this morning the cement front of the
AutoZone actually collapsed on to itself
to our Nashville station WT bf saw the
damage firsthand crushed cars filled the
streets and wit laxen scar was smashed
by a fallen sign I think I'm lucky to be
alive and I've got a lot to process the
tornado
filled the sky as it turned across
Tennessee State Capitol just before 1:00
a.m.
lightning and power surges were visible
leaving tens of thousands without
electricity and many people without
roofs over their heads firefighters and
police are already searching the debris
for trapped victims you can see behind
me this house is completely decimated
CBS Sunday morning producer Roman feasor
lives in Nashville's Rosebank
neighborhood his home is ok but his
neighbors say a tree fell through their
bedroom downed trees are everywhere with
some buildings reduced to mangled heaps
of metal the windows were blown out of
this business
when you're inside it was one thing but
to walk out here now and see everything
it's so the storm went through right in
the middle of the night the most
dangerous time for it to happen right
across downtown Nashville as you can see
judging by the damage it is not easy to
collapse buildings it had to be an ef3
or ef4 but we don't have confirmation
yet that means winds were likely over
150 miles an hour it could have been on
the ground for nearly 50 miles as you
can see we still have a tornado watch in
effect for Alabama through 11:00 a.m. so
watch out for more severe weather this
morning
all right very frightening stuff Jeff
thank you very much